توصلوا للاحزاب والتحالفات التركيه
استعداداتها لجوله الاعاده للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرره لاحد المقبل وفي سياق
المتصل تسلمت الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
اصواتها اتراك الخارج والتي بلغت اكثر من
مليون وثمانمائه الف صوت على يستمر
التصويت في المعابر الحدوديه والمطارات
حتى مسائل احد القادم وكان التصويت
بالخارج انتهى في الرابع والعشرين من
مايوير الجري على ان تفرز الاصوات بعد
اغلاق صناديق يوم الصناديق يوم الانتخابات
في 28 من مايو الجاري يوم الاحد
وقد دار الرئيس التركي ومرشح وتحالف
الجمهور رجب تايبر اردوغان الشعب التركيه
للاحتشاد عند الصناديق والتصويت له بكثافه
اضافه اردوغان انتخابه لجوله جديده يضمن
ما سماها تركيا القويه والعظيمه
اما مرشح المعارضه زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ومرشح تحالف والشعب كمال اوغلو
فقال ان رفض ما سماها اتهامات الحزب
الحاكمي له بعلاقته بالمنظمات الارهابيه
في اشاره الحزب العمال الكردستاني وقال
كالجدار اوغلو انما يصدر بهذا الصدد ما هو
الا محض افتراء حسب وصف
اما القياديه الكردي والرئيس السابق لحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي صلاح الدين دمرطاش فدعى
انصاره الى التصويت بكثافه لمرشح تحالف
الشعب وزعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوريه المعارض
كمال كالجدار اوغلو في تغريده نشرها على
صفحه الرسميه في تويتر حذر دمرتاش من انه
اذا لم يتحقق التغيير عبر الصندوق في
انتخابات جوله الاعاده لاحد المقبل فان
اقتصاد البلاد وديمقراطيتها ستكونان امام
كارثه حقيقيه حسب وصفه